[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey we're back with the delightful Mindy
Kaling everybody
now Mindy I know you like to keep your
dating and relationship life low-key um
but the sex lives of college girls all
the cast was here and we did red yellow
green flag and I was wondering will you
do that with me I love to participate in
an impromptu game that could get me
canceled I think that's fine and that's
how I feel about this talk show every
single day all right I'm going to detail
a hypothetical date and you can hold up
a red flag a green flag or a yellow flag
according to how you feel about it I'll
play along here we go okay your date
takes off their invisible braces in
front of you at the dinner table
foreign
well I mean I've seen worse if it was
like Timothy chalamet by the way if it's
telling me it's a Charlemagne you can
take his entire teeth and I'd be fine
okay your date only responds to your
text with long audio messages
yes I that I agree I can't I don't have
time for that no your date roasts your
new floral shirt and you know he's not
wrong but he does it
it's kind of okay a sense of humor
your date shows up 10 minutes late but
doesn't acknowledge it this is gonna
sound do you know what I mean if you
don't acknowledge it then it's a very
slippery slope I agree you have to just
say I'm really sorry this is what
happened this is why I'm late your dates
job title on their dating profile is
entrepreneur
yeah yeah only a yellow
see that's a flat out right for me you
know what I wish I could revise that
that is everyone on my dating app is an
entrepreneur AKA you don't have a job
um all right your date picks a location
closer to their house
I've done it yeah that's fine all right
your date takes a bite out of string
cheese instead of peeling it oh you know
I know my son does that I want him to
have a happy dating life totally
Charming on the first outing your date
brings home The Leftovers in a doggy bag
including yours oh no really see that
for me I would be I would think that was
so cute I'm like I'm like the fifth date
until eternity after we slept together
okay there's some familiarity
um okay your date is older than 30 but
still has two roommates
mm-hmm
you know you don't know people's
situations agreed um okay really quickly
what is your personal red flag what
would be a personal green flag that you
think we should all stay away from or
look for
um I still think
I'm I think asking about
your Ambitions is good yeah what you
want to know what people do yeah and if
like if men want to know what you want
to do I'd like to know if you do
something yes all I'm trying to find out
like you know if you have health
insurance that's always nice
what is a giant red flag in Behavior we
should all look out for
uh for me
and then this is going to be very
divisive if you don't like Indian food
then I'm probably
again this can work oh wait Indian food
so I think you don't like Indians oh no
I'm saying to you I like you I love
Indian food clearly the takeaway from
this entire interview is that we should
be in a romantic relationship
[Applause]
these all add up to a great long-term
monogamous relationship that's what we
should do thank you for playing Mindy
Kaling make sure to check out Mindy's
book Studio exclusively with Amazon
thank you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]